I build a lot of decks, or at least I
start working on a lot of decks.
However, the vast majority of these die
before ever reaching completion and
acquisition. Most of the time, I won't
get very far at all. I'll spend maybe 20
or 30 minutes digging around and
throwing stuff in a list before
identifying something I don't like about
the deck. Usually, either that I don't
like the plan I had in mind, or that the
plan I had in mind isn't going to be
consistently executable. In this video,
I want to talk about a different set of
decks though. The decks that do pass
that initial weed out phase, that seem
like promising ideas, that I spent hours
completing a somewhat polished list for,
but which I have since abandoned, never
to be returned to. To me, these are just
drafts clogging up my Archidekt account
that I might look back at as a reference
point later, but I think they can
actually serve as an instructive tool
for thinking about what makes a deck
idea that initially seems good, actually
good, truly worth constructing and
trying to play with. Because the reality
is that a lot of decks don't actually
deserve to be finished, and being able
to identify when you shouldn't finish a
deck based on your own preferences will
save you precious time and prevent you
from boring yourself trying to play dead
on arrival junk piles. I want to begin
with perhaps the most obviously flawed
idea, a Rograkh Thrasios Polymorph deck
I nicknamed Turbo Stacks. The idea here
was pretty simple. Rograkh is a zero
cost creature in the command zone, which
gives an easy Polymorph target, and
Thrasios is a sweet utility creature
that gets me into two other colors that
I want to be in. The eight creatures
we're using our Polymorph spells to spin
into are mostly big generic bombs with
some sort of nasty way to slow down our
opponents attached. Niv-Mizzet Parun,
Hullbreaker Horror, two different
Jin-Gitaxias, you get the picture. On
top of this, three of our 10 creature
Polymorph spells also target artifacts,
and we add an extra artifact Polymorph
spell to help us pop out one of our
three key artifacts. Nexus of Becoming
as an engine, God-Pharaoh's Statue as a
powerful stacks piece, and Proteus Staff
as a repeatable Polymorph effect. To
support this dual type Polymorphing game
plan, this deck would run a bunch of
creature token generators and even more
artifact token generators, which were
mostly built into the deck's supporting
categories like ramp and removal. The
overall goal was for this deck to be a
flexible mid-range deck, able to do
cheesy polymorph plays, but also to
pivot into grindier game plans and
crunch value into the late game with
Thrasios. And that flexibility was
precisely what I found appealing about
the deck. Like other cheese strategies
such as Rienne Maeter, polymorph can
feel a little all or nothing. Either you
land the big idiot and do some nasty
stuff with it, or you fall flat.
However, this design of free polymorph
target plus value engine in the command
zone, along with all the baked-in
utility, could mean much better
resilience. The deck also had a lot of
land ramp sorceries since that's what
was required for its creature and
artifact polymorph game plan. And that
sort of ramp base along with Thrasios
already makes for a difficult-to-stop
engine.
Finally, the three Commander's Storm
cards all let this deck come surging
back into the game even after it's been
shut down. And the idea of Echo Storming
to create five copies of Nexus of
Becoming is extremely tasty. So, what
was this deck's problem? Why didn't I
end up building it?
The biggest issue was that the deck was
simply too generic and generically mean
at that. Thrasios plus ramp is a very
generic game plan. All of my top-end
creatures were generic disgusting bombs,
with four being played in at least 7% of
Incolor decks, and another three being
infamously oppressive traders. The game
plan had essentially zero synergistic
core to it because a polymorph deck with
that many targets can't really have a
synergistic core to it. The cards it
finds can't be anything but generic
soul-crushing bombs. Polymorphing is a
cool mechanism to arrive at those bombs,
but that doesn't make them interesting,
either for me or for my opponents. So,
the deck got scrapped, never to be
returned to.
That said, with each of these three
decks, I think it's worth asking, was
there any of what excited me about the
original idea that could turn into an
interesting deck?
Well, Rograkh Polymorph does seem like a
workable core as an easy way to grab
from a selection of creatures while
still having access to a second
commander. But, I'd want it to be
something more specific than Thrasios.
If I were to take another crack at this
idea, it'd need to be with a partner
like Kydele or Sakashima that has a bit
more specificity. And then the things to
be polymorphed for would need to be far
less generic as well. The tricky thing
here would be finding enough options
that the deck would always be happy
with. With fewer than three Polymorph
targets, the deck would be in total
gimmick territory. While with too many,
the deck would risk ending up with a
generic and boring game plan once again.
Or alternatively, a wildly inconsistent
one.
Finding several different high-cost
cards that generally fill the same
specific niche within the deck is a
tricky task. But, that's the only way
I'd want to touch Polymorph again as a
primary feature of a deck.
If you're enjoying this video, you
should hit all the buttons you see on
your screen, each and every one of them.
You can also sign up for my Patreon or a
YouTube membership if you want to
support what I do here. And you'll also
get access to a companion piece to this
video where I talk about three more
decks I haven't given up on. A preview
of that will be at the end of this
video.
The next deck I didn't finish is one
that I nicknamed Goblin Throne, and this
one is far more recent. This is a deck
built around Throne of the Grim Captain,
a two-man artifact whose front side taps
to mill two cards, and which can exile a
dinosaur, merfolk, pirate, and vampire
from your board or graveyard to flip.
The backside is a 7/7 creature with a
bunch of keywords that also has an
on-attack trigger, forcing opponents to
sacrifice a nonland permanent, and
putting one of the typed creatures
exiled with it into play tapped and
attacking.
This is a fairly attractive hidden
commander to me for a bunch of reasons.
The colors are relatively flexible, the
creature types it uses feature a variety
of interesting designs, the card's
attributes make it findable with a
number of different conditional tutors,
and the front side of it is just a
decently costed graveyard enabler in its
own right. When I was first deciding
what I should do with this card, I
decided that Grixis was the easiest
color identity to work with, since blue
was the primary color for Merfolk, and
red was a great secondary color for the
other three types that also gave better
access to haste. Then, I decided I
wanted a commander that was graveyard
based in some form or other, sharing
either a graveyard setup or a graveyard
payoff with Throne. I'm also a sucker
for a low-cost commander, so naturally I
stumbled onto Norman Osborn, a looter
guy on the two-mana side and a powerful
discard payoff on the four-mana side.
This is a reasonably popular commander,
but the pairing with Throne of the Grim
Captain is relatively less common.
There's a lot to work with here, though.
Syr Elsha of the Grim Captain and
Flaming Tyrannosaurus as
madness-friendly dinos, all sorts of
looting pirates, multiple
graveyard-friendly Merfolk, and
basically the entire vampire subtype.
We've also got the incarnations to give
ourselves keywords when they're in the
graveyard, a couple beautifully fitting
extra combat cards to let us Grim
Captain even harder, and various other
unique cards that slot nicely into some
role or other. All sorts of cards I find
cool and exciting managed to work their
way into this deck. Streffen, Kira, the
Rising Tide, Captain Howler, Forbid, and
Necrogoyf. So, what went wrong?
On the surface, everything looks fine.
Unlike the last deck, this one decidedly
does have synergies. Its creatures do
feel more intentionally chosen, and its
game plan does seem more unique. Still,
my impression of this deck after
thinking about it longer is that it is
simply less than the sum of its parts,
and the sheer power of its commander is
part of the issue here.
I successfully identified that a discard
subtheme within these colors and with
these creature types was going to work
well, but my commander actually makes
that too easy. Whereas other
discard-oriented decks I play use unique
payoffs like Sharuum or Ox of Agonas
that want to be in a a specific type of
deck, Green Goblin simply lets me cast
anything I discarded that turn with a
two-mana discount, turning my cool
discard plan into a torrent of generic
Magic the Gathering gameplay. Now, this
might make it seem like the issue
primarily lies with the commander, but
really that's not quite true. Using a
powerful, somewhat more generic discard
commander like Norman Osborn to support
a more specific and textured game plan
could be a cool idea. But, Throne of the
Grim Captain just isn't that cool as a
thing to center a deck around. The card
itself is a graveyard enabler and a fun
payoff that can be a fairly significant
singular threat, but it's not really
well situated to anchor a game plan.
Likewise, the sort of deck construction
it encourages with a split of the four
different creature types is kind of fun
to build, but doesn't actually create a
coherent game plan to be amplified. It's
the Volo problem, a card creating
constraints that are fun to deck build
around, but which don't actually create
interesting gameplay on their own. While
this deck's cards outside of Throne and
Green Goblin have some graveyard and
discard themes that kind of work with
one another, it was a relatively generic
mid-range affair on the whole without
enough of an identity to feel like a
coherent deck. So, I scrapped the idea.
To be clear, I'm not against building a
Throne of the Grim Captain deck in the
future. The card still slaps even if I
didn't like this usage of it. However, I
think it would essentially need to be in
a mostly formed deck where the card just
happened to make sense. A deck where
Throne could add spice to a moderately
strong existing identity rather than
being expected to create identity all on
its own.
I actually did a little experiment while
writing this video where I tried to slap
together a different Throne of the Grim
Captain deck that solves the issues I
have with the card in this deck. I went
Mardu colors instead of Grixis with
Kroxa and Kunoros in the command zone
instead of Norman Osborn.
It was a sort of graveyard cheese
reanimator type situation with all
manner of spicy high-cost dinosaurs and
vampires alongside a bunch of graveyard
kneecappers and enough of the other
types to get by.
This deck had a distinct identity with
these different types, a punchy
aggressive play style, and a bunch of
congruence between the command zone and
Throne of the Grim Captain. The two can
work alongside each other, but they're
also rough analogs, which is nice for if
Throne gets removed or if I'm struggling
to keep the graveyard stocked for K&K.
So, every issue I have with Goblin
Throne is basically solved with this
cool reanimator deck. It's also not the
sort of deck I'm really interested in
playing. Kind of fragile and not wildly
flexible in its play paths. Just not my
cup of tea.
This is the challenge of deck building.
There are multiple elements that need to
line up in order to make a deck I'm
building worth finishing. And sometimes
solving one set of issues I have with
the deck just leads to an entirely
different set of issues.
What this means is that learning to
identify those issues early in the
process and hold back on finishing a
deck can be a helpful thing.
This channel is sponsored by Dragon
Shield. And if you haven't already, you
should check out their beautiful new
line of guild sleeves. These are dual
mats, so one side is the guild design
and the other side is a solid color that
provides a great backing for your cards.
Follow my link in the description and
use code Salubrious at checkout for 5%
off.
The final deck I didn't finish is one I
refer to as enigmatic control. And this
is the one I've spent by far the most
time thinking about. The pivotal card of
this deck is enigmatic incarnation, a
four-mana enchantment in Simic colors
that allows its controller to sacrifice
an enchantment on their end step,
searching up a creature with mana value
one greater to put into play.
Immediately, this is appealing as an
unconventional birthing pod effect.
Enchantment creatures are one obvious
application here, since an enchantment
creature can be sacrificed to find a
different enchantment creature, just
like a normal pod effect. But, there are
other interesting options as well.
Enchantments with ETBs make for nice
sacrifice targets, as do sagas, which
leaves quite a few different options.
There are also a number of
non-enchantment creatures to be grabbed
that have great synergy with an
enchantment sacrificing game plan such
as Tameshi, Harnessed Snubhorn, and
Moon-Blessed Cleric. This deck was
looking to assemble a solid toolboxy
sort of game plan with some of these
different options. Although, there was a
final challenge to be navigated of when
an Enigmatic Incarnation triggered on
the end step.
This is a little bit of a problem for us
because it means we can't get immediate
use out of any of the creatures we grab
in the way we could with a conventional
pod effect. No grabbing a card draw
creature to hit a land drop, no grabbing
a removal creature to enable a good
attack step, no grabbing a synergy piece
creature to set up some sweet spells,
and so forth.
To me, this meant two things. For one,
flash enablers were going to be a
notable part of our game plan so that we
can play more on our opponent's turns.
And two, this deck's general plan needed
to be a bit slower and more controlling.
These two features combined with an
enchantment-centered game plan also made
a particular type of card very useful,
Rule of Law effects. Preventing each
player from casting more than one spell
each turn can do wonders for keeping
people in check, especially in a deck
that has some counterspells to stop even
that one spell if it's a bit too spooky.
Realistically, this means that we need
white in our color identity. So, it was
at this point where I picked out a
relatively generic enchantment
commander, Tuvasa the Sunlit. Tuvasa's
draw is nice for taking a bit of strain
off our value engines, and the fact that
Tuvasa herself gets decently big with
enough enchantments on board also allows
her to be a win con for us. This feature
of the card is compounded by a few
evasion enchantments like Unquestioned
Authority and Thassa, God of the Sea.
And the fact that these can be simply
sacrificed to find something else if the
commander beatdown plan doesn't seem
doable is a nice bit of flexibility.
Aside from commander damage, this deck
had a handful of other options for
winning. Most of them a bit grittier and
more controlling. The deck featured
Karametra as a god that can give a ton
of ramp. And then there are some
different options for turning this mana
advantage into a lock of sorts. The deck
had several different enchantress
effects, and these could be paired with
Words of Wind to repeatedly bounce a
ramp enchantment, chipping away
resources from our opponents.
The deck also had Fear of Sleep
Paralysis in it, which could lock down
opposing creatures if we were playing
enough enchantments. Both of these are
tricky to pull off with a Rule of Law
effects still in play, unless we have
Heliod, the Warped Eclipse in play. But,
luckily for us, our deck is built around
sacrificing enchantments, so we have the
ability to get the Rule of Law
enchantments out of there whenever we're
ready.
Once we're heavily taxing our opponent's
ability to play the game, the idea was
to beat them down with an army of
enchantment creatures and or our
commander.
So, why didn't I finish up and buy this
deck?
Well, there were some pretty fundamental
issues, mostly all stemming from the
fact that Enigmatic Incarnation is not a
very good card. It's slow as a primary
engine since it's four mana and triggers
on end step, and though it synergizes
well with the Dusk Legion Overlords,
there are only three of those available
in the colors. Maybe there could be a
version of this deck where we dip into
the seven other enchantments in the game
that can get heavily discounted by
certain requirements being fulfilled,
but these cards tend to be highly varied
and not necessarily conducive to a
focused game plan.
Now, trying to pump up the strength of a
cool but mediocre card is not
necessarily a bad time, and that is
precisely what this deck is trying to
do. To accomplish this, there are two
main methods available to enchantment
decks, generic enchantress effects and
stacks pieces.
Both of these are fine, but they do kind
of clash with one another, particularly
the Rule of Law effects. Preventing
players from casting more than one spell
per turn prevents playing more than one
enchantment per turn cycle to draw cards
unless some of those enchantments have
flash. We could try to make them have
flash, but there will still be a natural
barrier to overcome every game. I could
dial in harder on a strictly enchantress
game plan, but that would lose a lot of
the appeal of Enigmatic Incarnation. It
makes a lot of sense as a toolbox
control card, and if I'm building a
generic enchantress deck instead, I
don't really feel like I'm building
around it. As a final option, we could
mostly give up on the generic
enchantment synergies and focus on
pushing our funky stacks game plan to
its limits. But, I think cards like
Citharus and Sanctum Weaver are kind of
required to keep this a mid-power deck.
And the lower this deck's power level
dips, the worse its identity starts to
feel as a staxy toolbox control deck.
Rule of law effects are pretty powerful
stacks effects, and it doesn't make
sense to fight low-power game plans with
high-power stacks. This isn't to say
that bracket two-style games should have
no interaction, and in fact, my bracket
two decks have above-average counts of
interaction cards, but the tools being
used should be a little lighter duty.
So, at the end of the day, I could come
up with cool play patterns around a cool
card, interesting branching game plans
for the deck to run down, but those
interesting game plans didn't flow
together in a way elegant enough to keep
up in the sort of Commander game I
wanted to keep up in. I could do a lot
of things and might end up in some
powerful situations, but at its core,
Enigmatic Incarnation just wasn't a card
that could give the deck the amount of
smoothing it would need to feel good in
the average game. And that's totally
ignoring the concept of an opponent
melting it with a removal spell
immediately. So, I scrapped the deck.
With all three of these decks, there was
something about them that excited me
enough to spend a lot of time building
them. I had some idea of the possible
challenges the deck might face, but it
took me a little while to fully weigh
what I found cool about a deck versus
what about it didn't seem all that
workable. With that in mind, there are a
couple of exercises I like to go through
now when I'm building decks to avoid
dedicating too much time to an
ultimately faulty idea.
The first of these is to think about the
basic plan for a deck and then to
consider how likely it is that that plan
will actually come together versus how
likely it is that the deck will do
something else. Ideally, it's pretty
likely that you'll fulfill the specific
vision you had in mind, but if it's
something more niche like a weird combo
or a hidden commander, it might be nice
to make sure that the deck is fun even
outside of that. The Enigmatic
Incarnation deck is an example of one
that kind of works with the enchantment
in play, but really does not function
smoothly at all without it. By contrast,
my Sharuum Astral Slide deck needs the
slide to hit its full late game
potential, but it's a reasonably fun
artifact deck even before that happens.
The other thing to consider is how your
deck's game plan fits into the context
of an actual game with actual opponents.
What sorts of decks will your deck be
playing against based on its power
level? What will your opponent's
experience with your deck look like?
Will your deck be good for multiple
enjoyable games, or will its get stale
for you and or your opponents fairly
rapidly?
This will usually be the bane of
Polymorph and other cheesy strategies
for me. These sorts of decks will clear
the bar of being cool in theory, but in
practice they're often boring to play
against more than once. And without that
freshness, I simply don't find them
interesting to play on my side of the
table, either.
This isn't to say that I can never make
a cheese deck work. Maybe a bunch of
factors all line up to make a deck
enjoyable for me. And it's also not to
say that what I find fun is what you
should find fun.
You might very well be able to take one
of the decks I've mentioned today, tune
it to your preferences, and then have a
blast with it. And that's great. What's
important is that you know what you
enjoy and what you don't enjoy, and that
you're able to check in with yourself
about a deck before dedicating too much
time to it. Remove the blinders of a
cool idea and give your deck a good
proper look. And if it's still looking
just as shiny, snag that bad boy.
Thanks for watching, and thanks to
Archidekt for supporting the channel. A
big part of what makes it possible for
me to start building so many decks and
not even delete the majority of them is
Archidekt's folder system. The fact that
I can separate my current decks from my
prospective decks from all the other
random things I do, like precon reviews,
lets me stay organized even with dozens
and dozens of decks on my profile. A
link to all of my decks is in the
description if you want to check those
out, including the ones I've mentioned
today. You can also check out my Timna
Kediss list I've been thinking about, a
deck that I've put on the back burner,
but haven't abandoned yet. I have a few
decks like that, and I talk about them
in a bonus second part of this video,
only available to patrons and YouTube
members. A A preview of that begins
right now.
To get into what I like about this deck,
I am a sucker for ways to pressure the
life totals of all of my opponents at
once, as Vial Smasher does, and Kediss
is quite an elegant way of doing that.
I'm also strangely okay with the Tymna.
In a lot of decks, I'd worry that such a
generically powerful partner would leave
the deck in a weird state with its
identity, but using it as a beatstick in
a full aggro deck makes it feel 100%
okay. Give me them cards. You'll also
see lots of pet cards for me that feel
right at home here. Commander storm
cards, chainsaw, Breena, Jeska, all
sorts of tasty cards.
Like the Blood Avatar ideas I'm working
with, this deck also fits into a niche
that I don't really consider fully
filled at the moment.